l'eau qui vous avez deux dragons mais
qu'est ce que vous attendez de moi
allez venu asseyez-vous
vous avez altérer la réalité
vous avez besoin du dieu de la malice
l'eau qui est imprévisible
je sais qui je suis
mauvais
un peu des deux en fait
[Musique]
bienvenue au tribunal des variations
anachronique je suis minute et mon rôle
est de vous informer avant que vous ne
soyez jugé pour toutes vos crimes alors
installé dans je ne sais pas
nous vous conduiront devant un juge en
mariant temps
mais qui peut croire à ces billevesées
critique et monsieur n'à
[Musique]
merci de votre visite dans les tpe
n'hésitez pas à le féliciter pour notre
éducation
qu'est ce que vous attendez de moi
vous avez altérer la réalité
je veux que vous nous aidiez à y
remédier pour quelle raison ça se
passera mal
deux filles à l'eau qui n'est pas une
excellente idée
j'aurai une arme c'est bon je sais vous
sans s'arrêter hors de question